a quantum entangled experiment performed
on this satellite showed that shared
quantum states can extend over 1,200
kilometers smashing the previous world
record quantum entanglement is physics
at its strangest subatomic particles
like photons can be entangled by sharing
their quantum states such as their spin
and polarization even if the photons are
separated by vast distances these shared
States should remained in limbo until
one of the objects is measured or
disturbed then the quantum states for
both photons suddenly collapse to a set
value with no information passing
between the two with fiber-optics
scientists have been able to demonstrate
quantum entanglement on earth across a
few hundred kilometres any farther out
and the photons quantum states are upset
by fluctuations in the atmosphere but
photons travel much more smoothly in the
near vacuum of space that's where the my
seus the first space-based quantum
research platform comes in inside Macias
an ultraviolet laser is split and sent
into a special crystal that produces
entangled photons with opposite
polarization states the pairs are then
beamed down to earth 5.9 million
entangled pairs per second to ground
stations in China over 1200 kilometres
apart receive the photons when the
scientists measured the states of the
incoming photons they were correlated
far more often than would be expected by
random chance evidence that the photons
had remain entangled across large
distances
although the transmission of the
entangled photons was much more
efficient than ground-based experiments
still just one in six million photons
made it to the base stations
next the researchers plan to distribute
quantum keys to the stations which
requires long strings of entangled
photons with entangled encryption keys
to people in separate locations can
communicate secretly with each other and
any attempt at eavesdropping would be
noticed researchers plan to extend the
reach of the fledgling quantum network
by adding more satellites in ground
stations that would be a stepping stone
to a space-based worldwide quantum
Internet
[Music]